I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. We are just rocking out to our own intro. We were actually dancing and miming the words.
我是珍娜·菲舍，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您制作独家的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女郎。我们正在随着自己的片头曲摇摆呢。刚才我们其实还在跳舞，嘴里比划着歌词。
Hello, everyone. Today we are going to be talking about The Fight. The Fight. Season two, episode six, written by Jean Stupnitsky and Lee Eisenberg, known to us as Jean and Lee. They're a duo. They're funny fellas. This episode was directed by Ken Quapas.
大家好。今天我们将讨论《打架》这一集。《打架》。第二季第六集，由让·斯图普尼茨基和李·艾森伯格编剧，我们叫他们让和李。他们是一个组合。他们是两个搞笑的家伙。这一集由肯·夸帕斯执导。
We love Ken Quapas. We love Ken Quapas. I don't even know if it's possible for people to understand our love of Ken Quapas. I don't know, guys. There are some directors that just are in our hearts, Ken Quapas, Paul Feig, Charles McDougall. Charles McDougall. For yelling action at us.
我们爱肯·夸帕斯。我们爱肯·夸帕斯。我都不知道人们是否能理解我们对肯·夸帕斯的爱。我不知道，伙计们。有些导演就是印在我们心里的，肯·夸帕斯、保罗·菲格、查尔斯·麦克道尔。查尔斯·麦克道尔。因为他总是对我们大喊“Action”。
For a different way, though. Yeah. Like Ken Quapas is like a cozy blanket, Paul Feig you want to hang out with all day and drink martinis. Mm-hmm. Charles McDougall, you kind of want to get drunk in a pub with and yell at people. It's so true. We'll talk about Charles McDougall when we get to him.
不过是用不同的方式。对。比如肯·夸帕斯就像一条温暖舒适的毯子，保罗·菲格则是那种你想跟他待上一整天、喝马提尼的人。嗯哼。至于查尔斯·麦克道尔，你可能只想跟他一起去酒吧喝醉，然后对人大喊大叫。太对了。等我们讲到查尔斯·麦克道尔时，我们会聊到他的。
We haven't really had a chance to talk about him, but that was a little preview. We have a special treat today. Our summary of this episode is going to be read by a fan. Dun dun dun. So here we go. Alexis is describing the fight. Dwight becomes assistant to the sensei at his dojo and spends the day bragging and telling everyone how tough he is.
我们还没真正有机会聊过他，不过那只是一个小预告。今天我们有一个特别的惊喜。这一集的剧情简介将由一位粉丝来读。当当当。所以我们开始吧。亚历克西斯正在描述这场打架。德怀特成了他道场里馆长的助手，整天吹牛，跟每个人吹嘘自己有多厉害。
Michael has a lot of papers to sign. Jim and Pam use the opportunity to trick Michael by saying they think Dwight is stronger than Michael is, so Michael agrees to duel Dwight at the dojo to prove his manliness and procrastinate doing his work. I thought that was very good. That was really good. I think she covered it. She was very concise.
迈克尔有很多文件要签。吉姆和帕姆趁机捉弄迈克尔，说他们觉得德怀特比迈克尔更强，于是迈克尔同意去道场和德怀特决斗，以此来证明自己的男子气概并借此拖延工作。我觉得这写得非常好。真的非常好。我觉得她总结得很到位。她非常简练。
I feel like maybe she wrote it down and read it, which is what I would do. So Alexis, I'm with you. You've made a friend. That's right. All right, let's get into the fast facts for the fight. Fast fact number one, this is the first episode from our new writing team of Jean and Lee. I emailed with Lee, Eisenberg, and he told me that before getting hired on the office, Jean was a part-time nanny and Lee was an assistant to a director.
我觉得她可能是写下来然后读出来的，这也是我会做的事。所以亚历克西斯，我支持你。你交到一个朋友了。没错。好了，让我们进入《打架》的快讯部分。快讯一，这是我们新的编剧团队让和李合作的第一集。我给李·艾森伯格发过邮件，他告诉我，在被《办公室》录用之前，让曾是一名兼职保姆，而李则是某个导演的助理。
This was their first staff writing job. They were over the moon and they were particularly excited about the free lunches. I can really relate to that because when I interned on Conan O'Brien, I got free food and I was so excited. Every time I got a job as an actor, when I was a struggling actor, I got excited about the free meals. The free food at work, I still get excited about it. I have to be honest.
这是他们的第一份专职编剧工作。他们高兴得不得了，尤其是对免费午餐感到格外兴奋。我对此真的深有同感，因为当我在柯南·奥布莱恩节目实习时，我能吃到免费食物，我当时兴奋极了。每当我作为一名演员得到工作时，当我还是个苦苦挣扎的演员时，我都会为免费的饭菜感到兴奋。工作中的免费食物，我到现在还是很兴奋。我必须老实说。
The snack tables. I hate to break it to everyone at Ear Wolf, but I hit up that fruit bowl hard every morning when we come here. Yeah. Like apple, banana. Ear Wolf has a basket of chips that's really good too. When I worked in offices in real life, I used to get really excited to go in the break room and someone would bring in some Danish or some muffins or cookies.
零食区。我真不想打破大家对Ear Wolf的美好幻想，但每次我们来这里，我每天早上都会疯狂搜刮那个水果碗。对啊。比如苹果、香蕉。Ear Wolf还有一篮子薯片，也非常好吃。我在现实生活中的办公室工作时，每当有人带进来一些丹麦酥、松饼或曲奇饼干，我都会兴奋得不得了，跑去茶水间。
I don't know. If you were anything like me, I would eat ramen noodles because you could buy nine for a dollar. Oh, yeah. Oh, man. You know, ramen noodles are really a great meal for family meals with kids. You can spruce it up. You can saute some brown chicken and put a bunch of veggies in with the noodles.
不知道你们是不是也像我一样，我会吃方便面，因为你可以一块钱买九包。哦，对。哦，天哪。你知道吗，方便面其实是给有孩子的家庭做家庭餐时非常棒的选择。你可以给它加点料。你可以炒点褐色鸡肉，然后在面里放一大堆蔬菜。
You can also not cook them at all and crunch them up and put them in a salad instead of a crouton. This is turned into a different show. Okay. That's like a, you can make a Chinese chicken salad. You can use ramen noodles as your crunchies. Wow. There you go.
你也可以完全不煮它，把它捏碎放进沙拉里代替面包丁。这节目怎么变成另一个风格了。好吧。这就像你可以做一份中式鸡肉沙拉。你可以把方便面当作脆脆的配料。哇。这倒是个主意。
Some more information from Lee about this being his first episode. He said they were terrified because remember we talked about how they break down the episodes as a group and then writers get assigned to write the episode. He said that since their episode was episode six, they had very little in their outline. He said they had fleshed out the other episodes much more than this one. And he thought that they were being set up to fail. And they were being tested. Yes, exactly.
关于这是他的第一集，李还提供了一些更多的信息。他说他们当时吓坏了，因为还记得我们说过他们是如何以小组形式拆解剧集，然后指派编剧去写剧集的吗？他说因为他们的剧集是第六集，他们大纲里的内容非常少。他说他们把其他集的细纲写得比这一集详细得多。他们觉得自己这是在被设定为注定要失败。而且他们正在接受测试。是的，完全正确。
Because he was like, how do you give the staff writers with the least amount of experience? The least worked on outline. Yes, exactly. He said after they turned in their script and they had to get their notes on their script, Greg had pneumonia and they had to go to Greg's house in order to get their notes. And he said the thing that really stood out to him was that he explained the idea of the Jim Pam subtext to Jean and Lee. They had written a really on-the-nose Jim Pam scene.
因为他当时在想，怎么能把经验最少的专职编剧……分配给大纲完成度最低的一集呢？是的，完全正确。他说在他们交了剧本并拿到剧本修改意见时，格雷格得了肺炎，他们不得不去格雷格家才能拿到意见。他说有一件事让他记忆犹新，那就是格雷格向让和李解释了吉姆和帕姆之间潜台词的概念。他们之前写了一场非常直白的吉姆和帕姆的戏。
And Greg said, sometimes just a look is enough. And he said it kind of blew their minds and that Greg completely brought that idea to them. And in the episode, something I remember is when Pam is reading Jim's poem, that was a big deal. And that was how there was always this discussion, how can Jim and Pam physically touch without it being inappropriate? Right.
而格雷格说，有时候一个眼神就够了。他说这简直让他们大开眼界，而且格雷格完全是把这个想法灌输给了他们。在这一集里，我记得的一件事是当帕姆读吉姆的情书时，这可是一件大事。当时总有这样的讨论：吉姆和帕姆如何在没有越界的情况下产生身体接触？对吧。
Well, lady, I think that was very intimate. I even looked up online about hand touching. And it is considered physical intimacy. That was some major flirting. That's a note card I have for later. All right. Should we move on to FastFact number two? Let's do it.
噢，女士，我觉得那非常亲密。我甚至在网上查过关于触碰手的资料。这确实被认为是一种身体上的亲密感。那可是相当大尺度的调情。这是我留着以后用的手卡。好了。我们应该进入快讯二了吗？开始吧。
All right. FastFact number two, Sensei Iroh was played by Lance Crawl. Is it Sensei or Sensei? Oh, my gosh. It's Sensei Iroh was played by Lance Crawl, who's a friend of mine. And I have five note cards on him because he and I talked on the phone yesterday. You know that I was very starstruck by him when he was on our episode. I know.
好的。快讯二，伊罗师傅（Sensei Iroh）由兰斯·克劳尔饰演。是叫Sensei还是Sensei？哦，天哪。是伊罗师傅由兰斯·克劳尔饰演，他是我的朋友。我关于他有五张手卡，因为昨天我和他在电话里聊过。你知道当他出演我们的那一集时，我对他是顶礼膜拜的。我知道。
He even said, I think Jenna watched a lot of Joe Schmo. Yes. That cracks me up that he said that. Because I did corner him at lunch one day and I made him tell me everything about the Joe Schmo show. If you guys have not seen this, please go look it up. The Joe Schmo show was a fake reality show contest where everybody on the show were actors except for one person.
他甚至还说，我想珍娜看了很多《求职残酷大赏》（The Joe Schmo Show）。没错。他这么说让我笑死。因为我有一天在午饭时把他堵在角落里，逼他把关于《求职残酷大赏》的一切都告诉我。如果你们还没看过这个节目，请务必去搜来看看。《求职残酷大赏》是一个虚假的真人秀竞赛，节目里的每个人都是演员，除了一个人。
The Joe Schmo guy was a real person and everyone around him was acting like they were in a reality show. Yes. They were acting in this house and they had to do competitions and vote each other off at the end. By the way, Kristen Wiig is on that show with Lance. A lot of great comedians and improvisers that I knew were on that show. I auditioned for that.
那个普通人是个真人，而他周围的所有人都假装自己身处真人秀节目中。是的。他们在房子里演戏，必须进行比赛，最后互相投票淘汰。顺便说一句，克里斯汀·韦格和兰斯一起出演了那个节目。我认识的很多优秀的喜剧演员和即兴演员都参加过那个节目。我去试镜过。
It was cast by Allison Jones and I was devastated when I did not get it because I thought what an amazing acting experience to live in a house and have to play this character 24-7. And by the way, this show is brilliant, so yes, I am starstruck by Lance. I can't believe you know him. I can't believe I didn't know that you know him. So I emailed him yesterday and I was like, Lance, we're going to be talking about the fight. Where are you?
那是由艾莉森·琼斯选角的，当落选时我心碎了，因为我想，能住进一栋房子里、24小时扮演这个角色，这是多么棒的演艺经历啊。顺便说一句，这个节目太精彩了，所以没错，我对兰斯崇拜得不行。我真不敢相信你认识他。我真不敢相信我以前不知道你认识他。所以昨天我给他发邮件说：“兰斯，我们要聊《打架》这一集了。你在哪？”
Can you hop on the phone? And he was like, I'm actually in Atlanta. He has moved to Atlanta and he set up his own production company because he's really talented. He's an actor, comedian, writer. And he has a production company in Atlanta called Picture It Productions. How about that? How about that?
你能接个电话吗？他说：“其实我在亚特兰大。”他搬到了亚特兰大，并成立了自己的制作公司，因为他真的很有才华。他是个演员、喜剧演员、编剧。他在亚特兰大开了一家名为“想象它制作”（Picture It Productions）的制作公司。怎么样？厉害吧？
Get out at PictureItProductions.com. All right, Lance. So we met so long ago and I said, Lance, did we meet doing improv? I can't remember exactly how we met and he remembered exactly and it made me laugh so hard. What? Okay. So he was friends.
去看看 PictureItProductions.com。好吧，兰斯。所以我们很久以前就认识了，我说：“兰斯，我们是在玩即兴表演时认识的吗？”我记不清我们到底是怎么认识的了，但他记得一清二楚，这把我逗得哈哈大笑。什么？好吧。所以他是朋友。
We had mutual friends and I went into an editing bay where a friend of ours worked and they were helping me with my acting reel. Okay. And I said, Lance, was this before the office? He said, no, Angela. It was like after the pilot, but you really didn't think the show was going to go. So you were trying to put some of your office like scene with Kevin and accounting in your reel.
我们有共同的朋友，我走进了剪辑室，我们的一位朋友在那儿工作，他们正在帮我制作我的演员表演剪辑带。好吧。我说：“兰斯，这《办公室》之前吗？”他说：“不是的，安吉拉。那是试播集之后的事，但你当时其实并不觉得这部剧能播下去。所以你当时正试图把你在《办公室》里和凯文在会计部门演的一段场景放进你的剪辑带里。”
Should we say what a reel is? Yes. Yes. So just for people who don't know, like, you know, actors have a headshot and on the back is their resume and you give that at auditions, but you also would send a link to clips of various performances you had been on and that's your acting reel. It helps you get jobs. Yeah.
我们要解释一下什么是表演剪辑带吗？对。对。所以对于那些不知道的人来说，你知道的，演员们有一张大头照，背面是他们的简历，你去试镜时会交这个，但你也会发送一个链接，里面包含了你曾参演过的各种表演片段，那就是你的演员表演剪辑带。它能帮你找到工作。对。
So you're putting together your acting reel with some clips from the office and this really dates me and our show because it was all on VHS. Oh my gosh. And there was a guy actually editing. Yes. And I had brought in like a box of all of my footage and they were putting together a montage of my scenes and Lance said, Angela, it was so cute and charming because you turned to me and you said, Hey, will you watch this?
所以你当时正在把《办公室》里的一些片段剪辑到你的表演剪辑带里，这真的很暴露我和我们节目的年代，因为这全都是在VHS录像带上。哦，天哪。而且当时真的有个剪辑师在剪。对。我带了一箱我所有的素材进去，他们正在把我的场景拼凑成一个蒙太奇，兰斯说：“安吉拉，当时太可爱、太迷人了，因为你转过身来对我说，‘嘿，你能看一眼这个吗？’”
Will you? What do you think of my reel? And he said, Ang, it was every second you've ever been on screen. He said it was so long and also in some of it, you didn't even have dialogue, you just walked by. That is hilarious. There was like a commercial like I did for Chrysler where I walked by and I just went and like did thumbs up at someone.
“你觉得我的剪辑带怎么样？”他说：“安吉，那里面有你在屏幕上出现的每一秒钟。”他说时间太长了，而且在其中一些片段里，你甚至没有台词，你只是从镜头前走过。太搞笑了。就像我为克莱斯勒拍的一个广告，我从镜头前走过，然后对着某人竖了个大拇指。
I was like, Oh my gosh, Lance, it's so embarrassing, but that's the first time we met. So it was after the pilot when I thought the office wasn't going to go and I was trying to figure out how to get more work. That's very funny that then he ends up being on the show. I know. And then he told me, he said, Ang, did you know I tested for the role of Jim? He tested for Jim. What?
我当时想：“哦，天哪，兰斯，太尴尬了，但那是我们第一次见面。”所以那是在试播集之后，当时我以为《办公室》播不下去，我正想方设法弄到更多工作。这很有趣，后来他居然能在这部剧里演个角色。我懂。然后他告诉我，他说：“安吉，你知道我为吉姆这个角色试镜过吗？”他为吉姆试镜过。什么？
So I must have done scenes with him. He said you weren't in his group on his test day. Okay. He had a different group and Bob Odenkirk was in his group for Michael Scott. Oh, yes. That's right. I was in the Steve Carell test group. Well, you know, something that's funny about Bob Odenkirk since you brought him up, I knew
所以我一定跟他对过戏。他说你在他试镜那天不在他的小组里。好吧。他有不同的小组，鲍勃·奥登科克在他的小组里试镜迈克尔·斯科特。哦，是的。没错。我在史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的试镜小组里。好吧，既然你提到了鲍勃·奥登科克，关于他有一件很有趣的事，我认识
Bob Odenkirk when I was auditioning for the office and we were both called. I was called to do Pam and he was called to do Michael. So we got together and we practiced together. Oh, but then I wasn't in his test group and I had thought, darn it. We worked a bunch of bits together. We were so excited to show them off, but he did this very funny audition where he brought in his guitar and he sang a song to Pam and we had worked it all out and we were going to ask if we could do it if we were paired together, but we never were.
鲍勃·奥登科克，当时我在为《办公室》试镜，我们俩都被叫去了。我被叫去试镜帕姆，他被叫去试镜迈克尔。所以我们聚在一起一起练习。哦，但后来我不在他的试镜小组里，我当时想，该死。我们一起排练了很多桥段。我们兴奋地想要展示出来，但他做了一次非常有趣的试镜，他带了吉他去，给帕姆唱了一首歌，我们都排练好了，本来打算问问如果我俩被分到一块儿的话能不能表演这个，但我们从来没有被分到一块儿过。
So Lance told me this great story that the day that he was screen testing, you know, he's in the lobby waiting. They were all kind of giddy that Bob Odenkirk was in their group. They were all really big fans of Bob's and Bob walked over to Lance and was like, hey, you want to run lines with me? And Lance was like, sure. And he said it was really cool and they like sort of went out in this lobby and ran lines like three or four times, like the scenes all the way through.
所以兰斯告诉我一个很棒的故事，在他进行银幕试镜的那天，你知道的，他在大厅里等候。当他们听说鲍勃·奥登科克和他们在同一组时，都有点兴奋。他们都是鲍勃的超级粉丝，鲍勃走到兰斯面前说：“嘿，你想跟我对对台词吗？”兰斯说：“好啊。”他说那真的很酷，他们就像这样走到大厅里，把台词对了三四遍，把整个场景从头到尾演了一遍。
He just thought it was a really cool moment. So Lance said when he read for Jim, he was like, you know, I really felt like I just tried too hard. And he said then when he got called back, when we were, once the show was up and going for the fight, he read that it was like a martial arts guy and he goes, oh my gosh. Lance's background is actually martial arts. He was in the martial arts community for 15 years. He has a third degree black belt in Taekwondo.
他只是觉得这是一个非常酷的时刻。所以兰斯说，当他为吉姆试镜时，他想：“你知道，我真的觉得自己用力过猛了。”他说后来当他接到回电时，当我们的剧集已经开播并进入正轨、正在拍摄《打架》那一集时，他读到剧本说那是一个练武术的人，他心想：“哦，天哪。”兰斯其实有武术背景。他在武术界待了15年。他是跆拳道黑带三段。
He was the sixth in the nation in his like weight category in 1992. He trained junior Olympic gold medalists like he was. Did they know this about him? I mean, I think they didn't. I don't know. But he said when he saw who the character was, he was like, oh my gosh. He said, I am not going to try to go for the joke at all. I'm just going to go in as if I'm like working with one of my students and teaching a class.
他在1992年的体重级别中排名全国第六。他甚至训练过青少年奥运会金牌得主。他们知道他的这些背景吗？我的意思是，我觉得他们不知道。我不知道。但他说，当他看到这个角色是谁时，他心想：“哦，天哪。”他说：“我绝对不打算去刻意搞笑。我只想以我平时教导学生、上课的那种状态去演。”
And that's what he did. He put no pizzazz on it. He went in and played it really straight and they loved it. They always loved that. Those are the people they always cast for the people who played it real. This leads me to my third fast fact, Angela. I know you might have more to say about Lance. No, no, no.
而他确实就是这么做的。他没有给这个角色加任何花哨的东西。他走进去，非常正经地演了下来，而他们非常喜欢。他们一直都很喜欢这样。那些真正认真表演的人总是他们首选的演员。这就引出了我的第三个快讯，安吉拉。我知道你可能还有关于兰斯的更多话要说。不，不，不。
Go, go. But this is a fan question. Is anyone on the cast trained in martial arts? That's from Will. So yes, Lance and also Rainn Wilson studied karate his sophomore year in college and is a yellow belt. I didn't know that. Yes.
你讲，你讲。但这是一个粉丝提问。演员阵容里有人练过武术吗？这是威尔问的。所以是的，兰斯，还有雷恩·威尔逊在他大学二年级时学过空手道，是黄带。我不知道这个。是的。
And I asked Rainn if the writers knew that and he said no. What a weird coincidence that they wrote this whole karate themed episode and Rainn is a yellow belt and Lance was a black belt. Yes. That is so wild. Okay. Do you have more Lance stuff? Because I interrupted your Lance cards with my fast fact.
我问过雷恩编剧们是否知道这件事，他说不知道。这是多么奇怪的巧合，他们写了整整一集以空手道为主题的剧集，而雷恩是黄带，兰斯是黑带。是的。这太疯狂了。好吧。你还有更多关于兰斯的事情要说吗？因为我用我的快讯打断了你的兰斯手卡。
He actually had a really funny thing that made me laugh. He said that when they got to the actual fight and the choreography of the fight, he said he was so surprised because there was no choreography, there was no stunt guy. He said literally it was like, okay guys, just two idiots try to hit each other. This was very early on. We did not have a budget. That's what I told him. For these kinds of things.
他其实有一件非常搞笑的事把我逗笑了。他说当他们拍真正的打架戏以及打架的动作设计时，他说他非常惊讶，因为根本没有动作设计，也没有替身演员。他说字面意思就是：“好了，伙计们，就让两个白痴试着互殴就行了。”这还是在非常早期的时候。我们当时没有什么预算。我就是这么告诉他的。对于这种事情。
I told him, I said Lance, this does not surprise me because they put Phil Shea, our prop guy in a box for hours. Yeah. There was no stunt person. In the early years of the office, I always felt like it was a show we were making in our garage for our neighborhood. I always felt like it was a one act play we were doing in someone's garage. As a kid, I used to do that, I used to put on plays in my garage and the garage door
我告诉他，我说兰斯，这并不让我意外，因为他们把我们的道具师菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）塞进一个盒子里关了好几个小时。是的。根本没有替身演员。在《办公室》的早期，我总觉得这是一部我们在自己的车库里为左邻右舍制作的剧集。我一直觉得这就像我们在某人的车库里排演的一幕剧。我小时候经常那样做，我会在自己的车库里上演话剧，而车库门
was the curtain. I would put chairs out on my driveway for the neighborhood kids to come see my show. It was like a puppet show or a variety show. That's what the office always felt like to me. Just like a bunch of us making a show in our garage. This won't be the last time you see Sensei Ira. He does come back in season nine in the episode Junior Salesman. He does?
就是幕布。我会在我的车道上摆满椅子，让邻居家的孩子们来看我的演出。就像木偶戏或杂技表演一样。这就是《办公室》一直给我的感觉。就像我们一堆人在车库里制作一部剧一样。这不会是你最后一次见到伊罗师傅。他在第九季的《初级推销员》那一集里确实又回来了。真的吗？
Yes. What does he do in that episode? He was actually there to interview for a job. Oh, I remember that. Dwight brings in a bunch of his old friends and weirdos to interview. And family members. Yes. Lance emailed me a great behind the scenes photo of him and the other people interviewing
是的。他在那一集中干什么？他其实是去面试工作的。哦，我想起来了。德怀特带了一群他的老朋友和怪咖去面试。还有家庭成员。是的。兰斯给我发了一张很棒的幕后照片，照片里有他和会议室里其他面试工作的人
for jobs in the conference room. He has his karate outfit on over a business suit. His tie is poking out. It's so odd. He was on season one and then on season nine, so he sort of had this great perspective of being on the bookends of the show. What a very, very cool thing. Yeah.
他穿着空手道服，外面套着西装。他的领带从里面露出来。太奇怪了。他既出演了第一季，又出演了第九季，所以他可以说对这部剧的开头和结尾都有着极好的视角。这真是一件非常非常酷的事。对啊。
Thank you so much, Lance, for taking time out of your schedule in Atlanta to chat me up. And we're going to call you again come Junior Salesman. Yeah, I love it. All right, let's take a break and we'll be back to Break Town the Fight. And we are back. Hello. This episode begins with a prank. Jim pranks Dwight by putting his desk in the bathroom.
非常感谢兰斯，能在你在亚特兰大的百忙之中抽出时间来和我聊天。等拍《初级推销员》的时候，我们还要打电话给你。对，我太喜欢了。好吧，我们休息一下，一会儿回来继续剖析《打架》这一集。我们回来了。你好。这一集以一个恶作剧开始。吉姆把德怀特的办公桌搬到了洗手间里，以此来捉弄他。
Oh, poor Dwight. This was a good one. This was a good prank. I like this one. You have to look for Kevin in the background at the end when he leaves one of the stalls. He has a lit candle and a newspaper. And for all of you office geeks, this was the moment that led to Kevin's line in Office Olympics about the bathroom candle smelling like cookies.
哦，可怜的德怀特。这个整得好。这是一个很棒的恶作剧。我喜欢这个。当凯文从其中一个隔间里出来时，你得注意背景里凯文的表现。他手里拿着一支点燃的蜡烛和一份报纸。对于所有的《办公室》铁粉来说，正是这个时刻促成了后来凯文在《办公室奥运会》里关于洗手间蜡烛闻起来像曲奇饼干的台词。
Also remember that in the dundies, he did win the Don't Go In There After Me Award. Yes. We see why. Also, though, guys, who is lighting candles inside the stall? Like, he doesn't come out and light the candle. He exits the stall holding a candle, a lit candle. Yes. And that candle really did smell like cookies.
还要记住，在邓迪奖上，他确实赢得了“别在我之后进那间洗手间”奖。是的。我们现在明白为什么了。不过话说回来，伙计们，到底是谁在隔间里面点蜡烛啊？而且他不是出来之后才点蜡烛的。他手里拿着一支蜡烛、一支点燃的蜡烛从隔间里走出来。是的。而且那支蜡烛真的闻起来像曲奇饼干。
I want to say that. Did you notice that there is another door by the urinal? Mm-hmm. Where does it go? We don't know. I like to think maybe... What is that door? Is it a utility closet?
我想说的是。你们注意到小便池旁边还有另一扇门吗？嗯哼。那扇门通往哪里？我们不知道。我宁愿觉得也许……那扇门是什么？是个杂物间吗？
I think that's what I think. I think there's like a mop in there or something. That's my guess. Yeah. Those bathrooms did not work. Nope. It was very deceiving. We would have people come visit us on the set like guests, family members, and they would
我想我也是这么觉得的。我觉得里面可能有一把拖把什么的。我猜是的。对。那些洗手间其实根本不能用。没错。太具有欺骗性了。我们经常会有访客来片场探班，比如客人、家属，他们会
go in there thinking that they were real bathrooms and they weren't. No. In the next scene, Dwight calls his sensei. Jim asks if he's talking to his mother. I love that. I think John is really good in that scene. And then there is his whole talking head about being a sensei, an assistant to the sensei. What is it?
以为那是真的洗手间就走进去，然而并不是。没有。在接下来的场景中，德怀特打电话给他的师傅。吉姆问他是不是在跟他妈妈说话。我太喜欢那个了。我觉得约翰在那个场景里演得真好。然后是他关于自己是师傅、师傅的助理的一整段内心独白。那是什么？
So yeah, Dwight says he's the senpai, which is basically like the assistant to the sensei. Yeah. Although... Not assistant sensei. Right. But also, actually, it's not him. It's like the girl, remember, because later in the episode, sensei Ira is like, there's my senpai.
哦，对，德怀特说他是前辈（senpai），这基本上就像是师傅的助理。对。不过……不是助理师傅。对。但实际上，其实不是他。就像那个女孩，记得吗，因为在这一集后面，伊罗师傅说：“那是我的前辈。”
So we learned that it's actually not Dwight. Oh my gosh, I missed that. Yeah. The girl that walks through the scene... Yeah. The senpai. Oh. I totally missed that.
所以我们得知其实那不是德怀特。哦，天哪，我错过了这个。对。那个走过场景的女孩……对。前辈。哦。我完全错过了。
All right. So next, we have Pam's talking head. And this is when we find out that today is the day that Michael has to sign time cards, purchase order approvals, and expense reports that they're all due at the end of the day. And this happens a couple times a year, and he always procrastinates wildly on these days. As a former secretary, I really relate to the dynamic between Pam and Michael in this episode because during one of my early secretarial jobs, I had a boss that would take so long to do his end of the month report that I would have to drive to the airport because the FedEx
好的。接下来，是帕姆的内心独白。这时候我们得知，今天是迈克尔必须签署考勤卡、采购订单审批和费用报告的日子，这些都在今天下半天截止。这种情况一年发生好几次，而且每到这种日子他总是极度拖延。作为前秘书，我真的对这一集里帕姆和迈克尔之间的动态感同身受，因为在我早期的秘书工作生涯中，我有一个老板，他处理月末报告总是拖那么久，以至于我不得不开车去机场，因为机场的联邦快递（FedEx）
at the airport had the latest drop time. I'm saying LAX Airport, which anyone who lives in Los Angeles, if I drive to LAX now, it's about a two-hour drive. So I would have to drive to the airport for like the 7 p.m. It might have even been 9 p.m. FedEx drop. Also, there's nowhere to park. And people are blowing whistles at you. Yes.
有最晚的收件时间。我说的是洛杉矶国际机场（LAX），任何住在洛杉矶的人都知道，如果我现在开车去LAX，大约需要两个小时的车程。所以我不得不开车去机场赶晚上7点。甚至可能是晚上9点联邦快递的收件时间。而且根本没地方停车。人们还在旁边对你吹口哨。对。
Like move out of the way. It's like chaos. I do love that Pam calls it the perfect storm. I do too. Also, though, Michael isn't having even to do any work. It's not like he's having to put together a report. All he has to do is sign them. No, that's right.
就像“快让开”一样。简直是一团糟。我真的很喜欢帕姆把这称为“完美风暴”。我也是。不过话说回来，迈克尔甚至不需要做任何工作。他根本不用去整理什么报告。他需要做的只是签字而已。不，没错。
It's so basic. It's just his signature. It could take him like 20 minutes. Yeah. And he'd be done. This is why I would get so mad at my boss who couldn't manage to get his report done because I would think to myself, it's not new information. It's a boilerplate report that you have to do every month.
太基础了。只需要他的签名。这可能只需要他花20分钟。对。就搞定了。这就是为什么我会对我那个搞不定报告的老板那么生气，因为我心里想，这不是什么新信息。这是一份你每个月都必须做的样板报告。
It wasn't a special project that sneaked up on us. Yeah. Time management, dude. You can see I'm still a little angry about it. Well, if I had to drive to the airport to mail something, I'd be ticked off for a long time. So next up in Michael's attempt to procrastinate, he tells Ryan to update the emergency contacts. So I enter that scene where Michael is telling Ryan to do the emergency contact list.
这不是什么突然冒出来的特殊项目。对啊，时间管理啊，老兄。你可以看出我对这事还是有点生气。好吧，如果我得开车去机场寄东西，我会气很久的。接下来，在迈克尔试图拖延的过程中，他让瑞恩更新紧急联系人。所以当我进入那个迈克尔让瑞恩做紧急联系人名单的场景时，
I was so concentrated on not laughing at Steve, who was being so funny in that scene. It took everything I had that when BJ would look at me and say the line, updating emergency contacts, I lost it. I started, it became, you know, in the scenes where you can't stop laughing and you have a trigger. Yeah. It was BJ turning to me and very sadly saying updating emergency contacts. I think I only got through one scene and I did it by not looking at BJ in the eye like
我当时全神贯注地告诉自己不能对着史蒂夫笑，他在那个场景里太搞笑了。我用尽了浑身解数，当BJ看着我并说出那句台词“更新紧急联系人”时，我彻底破防了。我开始……你知道的，在那些你笑个不停、有个触发点的场景中。对。就是BJ转过身来，非常悲伤地说着“更新紧急联系人”。我觉得我只顺利演完了一个镜头，我是靠不看BJ的眼睛来做到的，就像
I stared at his forehead. I spent nine years looking at Steve Carell's forehead because if I made eye contact with Steve, I used to say he would just like suck out your soul. You made eye contact with him through comedy. I could not lock eyes with him or I would start laughing. So I would, I would look at his forehead. Every conference room scene. I would have to do that or look at someone's ear.
我盯着他的额头。我有九年的时间都在盯着史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的额头，因为如果我和史蒂夫有眼神接触，我以前常说他会直接把你的灵魂吸走。你通过喜剧与他进行了眼神接触。我无法与他四目相对，否则我就会笑场。所以我只能看着他的额头。每一个会议室的场景。我都必须这样做，或者盯着某个人的耳朵。
Yes. Or their eyebrows. Yeah. Their neck. Yeah. It's just not in the eyes. Not in the eyes. Well, I thought that was a major PAMSAS moment.
对。或者他们的眉毛。对。他们的脖子。对。就是不能对视。不能对视。好吧，我觉得这是一个非常典型的“帕姆式犀利”时刻。
I think you have two really good PAMSAS moments in this episode and one of them is where you just walk out while he's talking and he's like, oh, she just left it. Well, he's finished talking, I was really channeling my real life experience working for that crazy guy. Michael gets Ryan's phone number in this episode. Oh, man. He's so delighted. He keeps calling him and doing voices and Angela flip phone, flip phone outdated phone
我觉得这一集里你有两个非常精彩的“帕姆式犀利”时刻，其中一个就是当他在说话时你直接走了出去，然后他一脸茫然地说：“哦，她就这么走了。”好吧，等他说完了，我当时真的是在代入我为那个疯狂家伙工作的现实生活经验。迈克尔在这一集里拿到了瑞恩的电话号码。哦，天哪。他太高兴了。他不停地给瑞恩打电话，还模仿各种声音，而安吉拉的翻盖手机、翻盖老式手机
is very featured in this episode as is my favorite thing is when Steve is Michael Scott cracks himself up. It's like one of my favorite things. Yes. We talked about this a little bit in the opening PAM reading Jim's palm. Yeah. I have that's a note card I'm going to reach for six minutes, 11 seconds. You guys major PAM and Jim a flirt happening.
在这一集中非常显眼，正如我最喜欢的桥段——当史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔·斯科特把自己逗笑的时候。这简直是我最喜欢的桥段之一。是的。我们在开场帕姆读取吉姆的手相时稍微聊过这个。对。我有……那是我的手卡，我在6分11秒处要用到的。伙计们，帕姆和吉姆正在进行大规模的调情。
So touching someone's hand is actually like that, like how you were tracing his hand. Yeah. Is a sign of physical intimacy. Yeah. Yeah. I know. So that was like, I was like, what is happening? Did you notice on my computer?
所以摸别人的手其实就像那样，就像你是怎么描摹他的手一样。是的。这是身体亲密接触的一个信号。对。对。我懂。所以当时我就想：“天哪，这是怎么回事？”你们注意到我的电脑了吗？
Yeah. I saw it. I saw that's like your decoy though. That's your way in. Yeah. Listen, these are two people who shouldn't be flirting, but so desperately want to be flirting. So they have to find ways around it.
对。我看到了。不过那是你的烟雾弹。那是你接近他的方式。对。听着，这两个人本来不该调情，但又无比渴望调情。所以他们必须找到迂回的方法。
So listen out there. If you see someone at work who's like trying to read your palm, oh, they might have a crush on you. They might have a crush on you. But I thought it was really cool that the set deck people put the palm reading website on my computer. Well, they had to justify why PAM was doing it. Yeah.
所以听好了，如果在工作场所看到有人试图给你看手相，哦，他们可能对你有意思。他们可能对你有意思。但我真的觉得布景美术人员把看手相的网站放在我的电脑屏幕上，这设计太酷了。好吧，他们必须为帕姆为什么要这么做给出一个合理的解释。对。
So here she is, bored at front reception. She says, Jim, let me read your palm, flirty flirt, sneaky flirt. I know. I see a note card that you have that is my next topic. Do you want to say it? Well, wait, do you like that this note card only has one word? Yeah. What's that word, Jenna?
所以她在这里，在前台感到无聊。她说：“吉姆，让我给你看个手相吧。”带着调情的意味，偷偷摸摸的调情。我知道。我看到你有一张手卡，正好是我的下一个话题。你想说吗？等等，你喜欢这张手卡上只有一个词吗？对。哪个词，珍娜？
Stacey. Stacey. Six minutes, 17 seconds. Oh my gosh, Brian, you would crack me up every time you said Stacey. It's only one word, but it goes through like four octaves. And we used to, that was like, we would, that was a bit on the set. We would cheat him. We'd be like, Stacey.
斯黛西（Stacey）。6分17秒。哦，天哪，布兰农，你每次说“斯黛西”的时候都能把我逗笑。虽然只有一个词，但它的音高跨度大概有四个八度。我们以前……那是片场的一个梗。我们会拿他开玩笑。我们会说：“斯黛西。”
At six minutes, 49 seconds, there's this whole scene with Jim and Dwight where they're talking and Jim is talking to Dwight about humans versus robots. Yeah. All right. In the background, Phyllis is at her desk. Stanley is not. Where's Stanley? Where is Stanley?
在6分49秒时，有一整场吉姆和德怀特的对手戏，他们正在聊天，吉姆在跟德怀特讨论人类对阵机器人。对。在背景里，菲利斯在她的办公桌旁。斯坦利不在。斯坦利去哪儿了？斯坦利去哪儿了？
Stanley never leaves his desk. He was never missing. Never missing. He's actually one of the characters that is probably the most featured at his desk. We used to joke about this. We would say, why do we all have to be at our desks in the background of all the scenes? Do none of us ever go to the bathroom? Do we never leave to go downstairs for a reason?
斯坦利从来不离开他的办公桌。他从来没有缺席过。从来没有缺席过。他其实是那些在自己的办公桌前出镜率最高的人物之一。我们以前经常拿这个开玩笑。我们会说：“为什么我们所有人都必须在所有场景的背景里待在自己的办公桌前？难道我们当中就没有一个人需要去洗手间吗？难道我们从来不会因为什么原因离开去楼下吗？”
None of us left our desk, but in particular, Stanley was always at his desk. He had to sit in the background of everyone's talking heads. He was always at his desk, but then you see as they pull back the camera that Stanley is at the file cabinet, but he never filed anything. To me, that was crazy. That's how I knew it was early on in the show, because after that, I think Leslie was probably like, yeah, no, I'm not filing. I'm sitting down.
我们谁都没有离开过办公桌，但尤其是斯坦利，他总是坐在自己的办公桌前。他不得不坐在每个人内心独白的背景里。他总是坐在自己的办公桌前，但后来当镜头拉远时，你会发现斯坦利其实是在文件柜旁，但他从来没有归档过任何东西。对我来说，这太疯狂了。我就是通过这一点看出这是剧集的早期，因为在这之后，我觉得莱斯利（Leslie）大概会说：“好吧，不，我不搞归档了。我要坐下来。”
I'm sitting down. At seven minutes, 40 seconds, Jenna, it's one of my favorite PAM sass moments. What is it? Okay. So Michael has a piece of paper and he's just like practicing his signature. Oh yeah. And then he taps on the glass and goes, you could practice on the forms. I mean, that is some really good PAM sass.
我要坐下来。在7分40秒时，珍娜，这是我最喜欢的“帕姆式犀利”时刻之一。是什么？好吧。迈克尔手里拿着一张纸，他只是在练习他的签名。哦，对。然后他敲了敲玻璃说：“你可以在表格上练习。”我的天，这真的是非常精彩的“帕姆式犀利”。
PAM is, it's such a great relationship between Pam and Michael because she is his subordinate, yet also his parent. Yes. In many ways. Oh yeah. She has to corral him, kind of like a sheep dog might corral the sheep. Yeah. Okay.
帕姆……帕姆和迈克尔之间的关系太棒了，因为她是他的下属，却又同时扮演着他家长的角色。是的。在很多方面都是如此。哦，是的。她必须管束他，就像牧羊犬管束羊群一样。好吧。
At eight minutes, 28 seconds. Oh man. This made me laugh so hard. We learned that Toby's emergency contact is still his ex-wife, even though her new last name is now Becker and he says, please don't put X. You don't need to put X. You don't need to put X. Okay.
在8分28秒时。哦，天哪。这把我逗得哈哈大笑。我们得知托比的紧急联系人仍然是他的前妻，尽管她现在的姓氏已经变成了贝克尔，而且他说：“请不要加上‘前’字。你不需要加‘前’。你不需要加‘前’。”好吧。
I have a screen grab. I'm going to show you. I took it with my phone at nine minutes, 42 seconds, Jim. When Jim is saying, you know, a ton of 14 year old girls to Michael, there is a brown object in the top left corner. At first I thought, oh, it's a boom. And I froze the, you know, the frame. I don't know if it's a boom or like an elbow.
我截了一张图。我要拿给你看，在9分42秒时，吉姆。当吉姆对迈克尔说“你知道有一吨14岁的女孩……”时，左上角有一个棕色的物体。一开始我想，“哦，是个麦克风杆。”于是我把那一帧画面定格了。我不知道那是个麦克风杆还是胳膊肘。
I don't know what it is. I'm going to show you a picture of it. All right. She's getting out her phone folks. Okay. All right. Tell me what the heck this is. And guys, I want you to look at it because it is what.
我不知道那到底是什么。我要给你看一张照片。好了。大家看，她要把手机拿出来了。好吧。告诉我这到底是个什么鬼东西。伙计们，我希望你们都看一看，因为这真的是……
We'll put this on officeladies.com. Oh, okay. Now I, and then I zoomed in. Do you see it? Yeah. Now look at it close up. What is that? And it's only in that frame.
我们会把它发到 officeladies.com 上。哦，好吧。现在我……然后我放大了。你看到了吗？对。现在仔细看看。那是什么？而且它只出现在那一帧里。
Is it Michael's shoulder or elbow or something? No. No. Michael is standing here. See his eye line? This is here. Michael's right here. I don't know.
那是迈克尔的肩膀、胳膊肘还是什么东西吗？不是。不是。迈克尔正站在这个位置。看到他的视线了吗？在这儿。迈克尔就在这儿。我不知道。
It's a brown orb, everyone. It's a brown orb. And I'm perplexed. Okay. Sorry. We've presented a mystery with no solution. I know. No, that's part of my superpower.
各位，那是一个棕色的球体。我对此感到困惑。好吧。抱歉。我们抛出了一个没有答案的谜团。我懂。不，那是我的超能力的一部分。
I'll notice things. I won't give you answers. We have to talk about what happens at nine minutes, 48 seconds. We have to. What happens? What happens? We learned that Michael and Dwight spent New Year's Eve together. Oh, yes.
我能注意到一些细节。但我不会给你答案。我们必须聊聊在9分48秒时发生的事。我们必须聊聊。发生什么了？发生什么了？我们得知迈克尔和德怀特一起过了跨年夜。哦，对了。
And that they watch, oh, they rented, that even dates the show. Yes. They rented Armageddon. Yes. And that Dwight cried at the end. Yes. Oh. And I actually.
他们看了……哦，他们租了……这甚至暴露了这部剧的年代。是的。他们租了《绝世天劫》（Armageddon）。是的。而且德怀特在片尾哭了。是的。哦。其实我……
But it was because, why did Dwight cry at the end? It's such brilliant writing. It's because it wasn't just the movie, it was that it began to snow. Yes. It began to snow. At precisely midnight. And it was like the perfect moment. I actually saw Armageddon with my dad because my dad's a drilling engineer.
但那是因为，为什么德怀特在片尾会哭？这编剧太绝了。因为不只是因为那部电影，而是因为开始下雪了。是的。开始下雪了。恰好在午夜时分。这简直是完美的时刻。其实我是和爸爸一起去看《绝世天劫》的，因为我爸爸是一名钻井工程师。
And so he was like, oh, this, you know, has drilling engineers in it. And we went and saw it and all like throughout the movie, anytime it was anything drilling related, my dad was like, nope, that's not how you do it. Never happened. That's not, nope, not up to code. That never happened. I was like, okay, dad. I went down the rabbit hole last night, like I do sometimes, like I went looking for the
所以他当时就想：“哦，这里面有钻井工程师。”于是我们去看这部电影，整部电影放映期间，只要有任何跟钻井相关的桥段，我爸爸就会说：“不对，根本不是这么操作的。从来没发生过这事儿。不对，不符合规范。这绝不可能发生。”我当时就想：“好吧，爸。”我昨晚陷入了资料搜寻的无底洞，就像我有时做的那样，就像我去找《求职残酷大赏》一样。
Joe Shmo show. I looked up Armageddon last night and I found a few different synopsises of what the movie was about. And it's too good to not read, Jenna. It's so, it's so classic, 1998 Michael Bay. Are you ready? I'm ready. When an asteroid the size of Texas threatens to collide with Earth in under a month, by
我昨晚查了一下《绝世天劫》，找到了一些关于这部电影讲的是什么的剧情简介。内容太精彩了，不读出来真的可惜了，珍娜。这太经典了，1998年迈克尔·贝式的风格。准备好了吗？我准备好了。当一颗得克萨斯州大小的小行星威胁要在不到一个月的时间里与地球相撞时，顺便说一句，
the way, NASA honcho Dan Truman, played by Billy Bob Thornton, determines the only way to stop it is to drill its surface and detonate a nuclear bomb inside the asteroid. This leads him to renowned Driller, Harry Stamper, played by Bruce Willis, who agrees to helm the dangerous space mission provided he can bring along his own ragtag crew. Among them is Cockshur, AJ, played by Ben Affleck, who Harry thinks isn't good enough for his daughter, Liv Tyler, until the mission proves otherwise. Wow. I mean, wow.
由比利·鲍伯·松顿（Billy Bob Thornton）饰演的美国宇航局大佬丹·特鲁曼（Dan Truman）断定，阻止它的唯一方法就是在其表面钻孔并在小行星内部引爆一枚核弹。这促使他找到了由布鲁斯·威利斯（Bruce Willis）饰演的知名钻井专家哈里·斯坦珀（Harry Stamper），后者同意率领这项危险的空间任务，前提是他可以带上自己的一帮乌合之众。其中包括由本·阿弗莱克（Ben Affleck）饰演的 AJ·库克舒（Cockshur, AJ），哈里觉得他配不上自己的女儿丽芙·泰勒（Liv Tyler），直到这项任务证明了并非如此。哇。我的意思是，哇。
Come on. So your dad was Bruce Willis. My dad was Bruce Willis. The Driller, the drilling expert. And he felt that everything Bruce Willis's character had to say was inaccurate. I would say the two movies my dad got really mouthy about were Armageddon and Twister. Twister, the tornado movie. Yeah, because we live in tornado alley and they were like driving up on this tornado
拜托。所以你爸爸就是布鲁斯·威利斯。我爸爸就是布鲁斯·威利斯。那个钻井工，那个钻井专家。而他觉得布鲁斯·威利斯饰演的角色所说的一切都不准确。我会说我爸爸看得很来劲的两部电影是《绝世天劫》和《龙卷风》（Twister）。《龙卷风》那部关于龙卷风的电影。对，因为我们住在龙卷风走廊，他们竟然开车冲向龙卷风，一辆卡车在空中飞舞，就像一辆巨型半挂卡车在空中飞舞，牛也在空中飞舞，然后那个家伙——我想是比尔·帕克斯顿——说：“我们遇到了一些碎片（debris）”，我爸爸就说：“碎片个屁啊。”不管怎样。
and a truck flies in the air, like a giant semi truck flies in the air, cows are flying in the air, and the guy goes, I think it's Bill Paxson goes, we've got some debris and my dad goes, debris my ass. I don't know. Anyway. We have to discuss the fact that Pam wants French onion chips. I love French onion chips. Gross.
我们必须讨论一下帕姆想要法式洋葱味薯片这件事。我喜欢法式洋葱味薯片。太恶心了。这是……我有个问题想问你。那是你个人的选择，还是帕姆……那是剧本里写好的吗？我不知道，但我觉得这可能是我个人的选择，因为很多时候如果你必须在镜头前吃东西，他们会问你的意见。确实。他们会问你有没有什么食物过敏。
Was that, I have a question for you. Was that your personal pick or did Pam, was that scripted? I don't know, but I feel like it could have been my personal pick because a lot of times if you have to eat something, they ask you. They do. They ask you if you have any food allergies. The props person will call you at home and say, we're doing a dinner scene. Is there anything you can't eat?
道具组人员会打电话到你家里说：“我们要拍一场晚餐戏。有什么是你不能吃的吗？”对。整部剧拍下来大概会变成：“珍娜，万一你得在镜头前打开包装吃薯片，你想要哪一包？”对。所以你说了法式洋葱味薯片。对。这意味着你那天剩下的时间里不能跟任何人调情了，因为你的口气会极其恶心。
Yeah. The whole show would have been like, Jenna, what bag of chips would you want in case you have to open them up and eat them? Yeah. So you said French onion chips. Yeah. This means you wouldn't have been flirting with anyone the rest of the day because your breath would be disgusting.
好吧，这倒是个好点子。我当时确实没考虑到这一点。我也很喜欢烤肉味的薯片。我能跟你透露一点关于薯片的信息吗？可以。好吧。赫尔斯薯片（Herr's chips，H-E-R-R-S），这是宾夕法尼亚州的一家本地公司，赫尔斯薯片。
Well, that's a good point. I didn't really think of that. I also like a barbecue chip. I love a barbecue chip. Can I tell you a little bit of information about the chips? Yeah. Okay. The Hersh chips, H-E-R-R-S, and this is a local Pennsylvania company, the Hersh chip.
我在翻我的纸张，因为我本来打算稍后讲这个的。也许你应该把它写在手卡上。哦，我明白了。不，我只是说说。看看我找信息有多容易。一点安吉拉式的犀利，各位。一点安吉拉式的犀利。好吧。
I'm flipping my papers because I was going to talk about this later. Maybe you should have written it on a note card. Oh, I see. No, I'm just saying. Look how easy it is for me to see my information. A little bit of Angela sass, everyone. A little bit of Angela sass. All right.
找到了。在这里。它就在我们的自动售货机里，所以你能在里面找到它们。我只是觉得我们用本地的东西来充实这个世界，这真的很酷。这是一个挺酷的故事，关于赫尔斯薯片的故事。我掉进了资料搜寻的无底洞里，安吉拉。好吧，听着。
Here it is. I found it. Okay. It's in our vending machine, so you can spy them in there. I just think it's cool that we used local stuff to fill out the world. It's kind of a cool story, the story of Hersh chips. I went down to rabbit hole, Angela. Well, listen.
给你。我找到了。好吧。它在我们的自动售货机里，所以你可以在里面看到它们。我只是觉得我们用本地的东西来填充这个世界很酷。这是一个挺酷的故事，赫什薯片的故事。我深入了解了一番，安吉拉。好吧，听着。
If I just read you the synopsis of Armageddon, you better tell me about Hersh. Guys, James Herr broke with his family's history of chicken farming. In 1946, he bought a potato chip company. He was only 21 years old, and he bought it for $1,750. Wow. Yeah. And now it's a huge successful company, and you can even go there and tour it. You would love that.
如果我只是把《绝世天劫》的剧情梗概读给你听，你最好跟我讲讲赫尔什的事。各位，詹姆斯·赫尔突破了家族养鸡的历史。1946年，他买下了一家薯片公司。当时他只有21岁，收购价是1750美元。哇。没错。现在它成了一家非常成功的大公司，你甚至可以去那里参观。你会喜欢的。
You can tour the facility. You love a factory tour. You know I love a factory tour. Angela, we've been invited to tour the sass factory in San Antonio. They said they would send us some shoes. I want them. I know. I want some sass shoes.
你可以参观那个设施。你最喜欢工厂参观了。你知道我喜欢工厂参观。安吉拉，我们受邀去圣安东尼奥参观萨斯鞋业工厂。他们说会给我们寄一些鞋子。我想要。我知道。我想要几双萨斯鞋。
I'm excited about that. And then, I mean, listen, if we're talking factory tours, Jenna, I don't even know how to tell you this. You're going to be so jealous. But next week, I am going to the Tefshed factory. For yours. That's what she said. For mine.
我对这个感到很兴奋。然后，我是说，听着，如果我们谈论工厂参观，珍娜，我都不知道该怎么告诉你。你会非常嫉妒的。但下周，我要去特夫谢德工厂。为了你的。那是她说的。为了我的。
That's what she said. I'm going to the Tefshed factory. I'm so excited. You guys, this is a weird thing that happens to us. I went and bought some tile. I needed some tile because I was doing a renovation outside. And I went to this tile showroom, it's called Arto Tile in Los Angeles, and they geeked out and they recognized me and they gave me a factory tour.
那是她说的。我要去特夫谢德工厂。我太兴奋了。你们知道吗，这是发生在我们身上的一件怪事。我去买了一些瓷砖。我需要一些瓷砖，因为我在外面搞装修。我去了这个瓷砖展厅，它叫洛杉矶的阿尔托瓷砖，他们激动坏了，认出了我，还带我参观了工厂。
This is a really cool perk. Yes. If you like to see how things are made. I love to see how things are made. I love that show. How it's made. How it's made. It's so good.
这是一个非常酷的额外福利。是的。如果你喜欢看东西是怎么制造的话。我喜欢看东西是怎么制造的。我喜欢那个节目。《怎么做到的》。《怎么做到的》。太棒了。
I know. And so I've gone on quite a few factory tours as a result of my fame on the office. You have. This is my first factory tour. Tefshed is my first one and I'm very excited, Jenna. All right. I wish I could go with you. So something I have to talk about, Angela, before we go to break, is the scene at Michael
我知道。因此，由于我在《办公室》里的名气，我去了不少工厂参观。你确实去了。这是我的第一次工厂参观。特夫谢德是我的第一次，我非常兴奋，珍娜。好的。我真希望我能跟你一起去。所以，安吉拉，在我们休息之前，我不得不谈谈的一件事，就是迈克尔
and Jim's desk when Michael talks about being in the damn rascals, his street gang. This is the same scene where they talk about Armageddon. But when Dwight punches Michael in the stomach, he does the double punch and Steve gets hit and he's like, that was John's weak spot. John would laugh so, so hard. And I think that's why in that scene, there is not a single shot of John's face. If you watch it after he punches Michael in the stomach, he, you never see John's face. Yes.
和吉姆的办公桌旁发生的那场戏，当时迈克尔谈到自己曾加入“该死的恶棍”这个街头帮派。这就是他们谈论《绝世天劫》的同一场戏。但当德怀特打了迈克尔的肚子时，他使出了双重击打，史蒂夫被打中了，他就说，那是约翰的弱点。约翰会笑得非常、非常厉害。我想这就是为什么在那场戏里，没有一个约翰正脸的镜头。如果你看他打了迈克尔肚子之后的镜头，你永远看不到约翰的正脸。是的。
He couldn't get through that. He couldn't get through that. He loved whenever Steve couldn't get a word out. Yeah. Especially in pain. Like, yeah. We'll talk about that later. We'll talk about, but, you know, Kevin sits on Michael's lap when he's Santa.
他根本过不去那一关。他过不去那一关。每当史蒂夫说不出话来的时候，他总是乐此不疲。是的。特别是在痛苦的时候。就像，是的。我们稍后会谈到这个。我们会谈到的，但是，你知道，当凯文扮演圣诞老人时，他坐在迈克尔的膝盖上。
Oh, yes. And Steve let out like a painful moan and I didn't think John was going to be able to get back from that. So this reminds me of that bit that Steve did on the Dana Carvey show, The Gnoshest Waiter. It's one of the funniest things I've ever seen. You guys have to look it up. Steve did it for us one time when we were in the conference room together.
哦，是的。史蒂夫发出了痛苦的呻吟，我以为约翰缓不过劲来了。这让我想起了史蒂夫在《达纳·卡维秀》里表演的那个小品——恶心服务生。这是我见过最好笑的事情之一。你们一定要去搜来看看。有一次我们一起在会议室的时候，史蒂夫为我们表演过。
And this is, John couldn't handle it. I was crying. I thought John was going to die. I thought John was going to die, but we were we were weeping. We were, you know, when you start laughing, where all you do is shake and make no noise. Yes. Because Steve would do this thing. So the waiter, he's a waiter, but food makes him nauseous.
这简直，约翰根本承受不了。我都哭了。我以为约翰要笑死了。我以为约翰要笑死了，但我们都在痛哭流涕。我们，你知道那种你开始大笑，以至于只能浑身发抖却发不出一点声音的状态吗？是的。因为史蒂夫会做那种动作。所以那个服务生，他是个服务生，但食物让他感到恶心。
So he would walk up to a table and have to give the specials of the day. So he'd be like, so ask me, Jenna, what are the specials of the day? What are the specials of the day? Well, we have brah, brah, brah, like he would start, start to puke. As he listed off the specials. Yes. He'd be like, we have a delicious chicken with a cream sauce or cream, sorry, cream sauce.
所以他走到一张桌子旁，必须报出当天的特色菜。所以他会说，来吧，问我，珍娜，当天的特色菜是什么？当天的特色菜是什么？嗯，我们有呃、呃、呃，就像他开始那样，开始呕吐。当他列出特色菜的时候。是的。他会说，我们有美味的奶油酱鸡肉或者奶油，抱歉，奶油酱。
It was so hilarious. It's so good. We are not doing it justice. We are not doing justice to it at all. Oh my gosh. If Steve ever comes on our podcast, do you think he would do that? Yes. Oh, I think he would.
太滑稽了。太棒了。我们根本没有演出它的精髓。我们根本没有把它演到位。哦天哪。如果史蒂夫以后上我们的播客，你觉得他会表演这个吗？会。哦，我觉得他会。
I made him to do it. Oh, Steve, come on and do nauseous waiter for us. Yes. We would, we would make him do that. We loved that. Angela, I think we should go to a break. I think we should. I would like to go eat some chips, maybe, maybe some sour cream and onion chips from
我得让他演。哦，史蒂夫，来给我们表演一下恶心服务生吧。会的，我们会让他表演的。我们太喜欢了。安吉拉，我觉得我们该去休息一下了。我也这么觉得。我想去吃点薯片，也许，也许来点酸奶油洋葱味薯片，从
the basket. Well, clearly you just want to be the gift that keeps on giving in here. Yes. All right, we'll see you in a second. We're back from break. Angela. Yes. I have a time code.
那个篮子里。好吧，显然你只想成为这里源源不断的惊喜。是的。好的，我们一会儿见。我们休息回来了。安吉拉。有何贵干。我有时间码。
What? Yeah. I actually, I have three time codes. Jenna, I'm so proud of you. Thank you. I almost wrote them on note cards and brought in three note cards, but I didn't want to infringe on your note card thing. First of all, I don't own note cards.
什么？对。其实，我有三个时间码。珍娜，我为你感到骄傲。谢谢。我差点把它们写在便签卡上，带了三张便签卡来，但我不想侵犯你的便签卡专利。首先，我根本没有便签卡。
I encourage you. I love it. Use it. I mean, Jenna, you don't own a list. I hate to break it to you. I might come in someday with a list. I think that's fantastic. What is your time code?
我鼓励你。我很喜欢。用吧。我是说，珍娜，你连个单子都没有。真不好意思打击你。我哪天可能会带个单子来。我觉得那太棒了。你的时间码是多少？
Well, I was very excited. It's 11 minutes, 50 seconds, and it is the scene where Pam and Jim are walking to the kitchen. John is snapping his fingers like he's from West Side Story, and we got tons of questions about these finger snaps, which I think is why I felt compelled to write down the time code. The question was, was this scripted or improvised? I remember it as being improvised, and I remember being so tickled by it because I'm a huge
嗯，我很兴奋。是11分50秒，也就是帕姆和吉姆走向厨房的那场戏。约翰打着响指，就像他是《西区故事》里的人一样，我们收到了大量关于这些响指的问题，我想这就是为什么我忍不住把时间码写下来的原因。问题是：这是剧本里写的还是即兴发挥的？我记得是即兴发挥的，而且我记得当时觉得特别逗，因为我是个超级
movie musical fan, and I asked Lee Eisenberg, and he thinks it was also improvised. He does not remember writing that. I think it was improvised because it's just like John kind of playing around because earlier in the show, he had mentioned, oh, like a jet, and Michael, I think, thinks he's a jet. He's like, oh, you're a jet? That was the name of your actual gang. Yeah. So I think John is just playing off of that reference.
电影音乐剧迷，我问过李·艾森伯格，他觉得那也是即兴发挥的。他不记得自己写过这个。我觉得是即兴发挥的，因为这就像是约翰在开玩笑，因为在节目早期，他曾提过，哦，就像一架喷气机，而迈克尔，我猜，以为他是一架喷气机。他说，哦，你是一架喷气机？那是你们真正帮派的名字。是的。所以我觉得约翰只是在呼应那个梗。
It was so fun. So then they go into the kitchen, and I have to say, this scene in the kitchen between Michael and Dwight, when they face off, might be one of my favorite scenes from the entire second season of The Office. In the kitchen, John and I almost started laughing about a million times, and if you notice, if you look at Mindy, she is constantly turning her back to the scene and looking into the annex. I could see you and John almost break.
太有趣了。然后他们走进厨房，我必须说，厨房里迈克尔和德怀特对峙的这场戏，可能是《办公室》第二季中最让我喜爱的戏份之一。在厨房里，我和约翰差点笑了一百万次，如果你注意看，如果你看门迪，她一直在把背转向镜头并看着走廊。我能看出你和约翰差点笑场。
When I watched this knowing you guys, I was like, oh, they were about to lose it. Seriously, watch Mindy through this because she cannot face the scene. It's amazing. Well, when Rainne grabs her and is like, all right, now from behind, she's like, wait, what? Amazing. I don't know how she got through that. And there's all these great things in this.
当我带着对你们的了解看这场戏时，我想，哦，他们快要憋不住了。说真的，看门迪在这场戏里的表现，因为她根本不敢面对镜头。太惊人了。嗯，当雷恩抓住她，说，好了，现在从后面来，她就像是，等等，什么？太惊人了。我不知道她是怎么撑过这一段的。里面有这么多精彩的细节。
This is the misuse of common phrases like catch 22, tit for tit. That's your favorite. My favorite, this is the second time he has said it, tit for tit. So two hits, me punching you and you hitting the floor. So good. It was just so good. This leads me into my second time code, Angela. Okay.
这里有对常用短语的误用，比如第22条军规，以牙还牙。那是你的最爱。我的最爱，这是他第二次这么说了，以牙还牙。所以有两次打击，我打你，你倒在地上。太棒了。真的是太棒了。这让我引出了我的第二个时间码，安吉拉。好的。
13 minutes, 27 seconds. Well I have one at 1325. All right. What's yours? Let's see. Well, this is at 1325, you see who actually goes to the dojo because you see everyone pile into the elevator. And it is Phyllis Pam Meredith, Oscar Creed, Kevin, Jim, Michael, and Dwight.
13分27秒。我这里有一个13分25秒的。好吧。你的是多少？让我看看。嗯，这是在13分25秒，你可以看到到底是谁去了道场，因为你看到所有人蜂拥挤进电梯。他们是菲利斯、帕姆、梅雷迪思、奥斯卡、克里德、凯文、吉姆、迈克尔和德怀特。
And who does not go to the dojo, Angela, Stanley, Toby, Kelly, and Ryan. Is that true? So you did not go to, did you not film that day when we went? I had the day off. Oh my gosh. Yeah. It was decadent. It was decadent.
而谁没有去道场呢，安吉拉？斯坦利、托比、凯利和瑞恩。是真的吗？所以你没去，我们去的那天你没去拍戏吗？我那天放假。哦天哪。是的。太奢侈了。太奢侈了。
Oh my goodness. So when I talk about being at the dojo, you're going to hear what you missed out on. Yeah. I have no idea. And you know, the thinking was that Angela and Stanley would not participate in this. It's like shenanigans and they are literally there to do work and clock in and clock out. Yes. And so Angela and Stanley are really two of the big bah humbugs of the office.
哦天哪。所以当我说我在道场时，你会听到你错过了什么。是的。我完全不知道。你知道，当时的设想是安吉拉和斯坦利不会参与其中。这就像是胡闹，而他们去那里纯粹是为了工作、打卡上班和打卡下班。是的。所以安吉拉和斯坦利真的是办公室里两个最大的扫兴鬼。
Toby and Kelly wouldn't go or Ryan because as you know, and I know they were writers and they needed to be in the writer's room and this was an opportunity for them to get some work done. Yes. It's so true. Well, when we all pile in the elevator, I don't know why I'm so tickled by it, but at 13 minutes and 27 seconds, just watch Kevin's face as the elevator doors close. Okay.
托比、凯利或瑞恩没有去，因为如你我所知，他们是编剧，他们需要待在编剧室里，这对他们来说是个赶工的好机会。是的。确实如此。好吧，当我们一起挤进电梯时，我不知道为什么我觉得这么逗，但在13分27秒，当电梯门关上时，看一眼凯文的表情。好吧。
It just makes me laugh. All right. He's got this little mischievous look on his face like he's very excited to see what's going to happen. Totally like a little kid who got to leave school. Oh, that's so cute. I love it. All right.
他脸上带着那种淘气的表情，好像对接下来要发生的事情感到非常兴奋。完全就像一个放学了的小孩。哦，太可爱了。我喜欢。好的。
Well, Angela, I'm going to tell you some stuff. The day that we shot at the dojo, it was really hot. I was going to say, were you guys all hot and sweaty? Yes. The air conditioning in our trailers wasn't working. Oh. So remember on the dundies when they had ants? This time they had no air conditioning and they were, they're metal.
好吧，安吉拉，我要告诉你一些事。我们在道场拍摄的那天，天气非常热。我正想问，你们是不是都又热又出汗？是的。我们拖车的空调坏了。哦。还记得拍邓迪奖的时候有蚂蚁吗？这次他们没有空调，而且那是金属的。
So it was kind of like changing your clothes in a sauna. And we were just super sweaty, all of us, and gross. And I had to wear a sweater because we had established my beige sweater earlier in the office. And I remember thinking, oh my God, I am so sweaty and stinky. And John has to pick me up. This is, this is a thing that I think people don't think about. You know, anytime I would have a scene where I would have to whisper at someone or you'd
所以感觉就像在桑拿房里换衣服一样。我们所有人身上都超级多汗，黏糊糊的。而且我还得穿一件毛衣，因为我们在办公室里已经确立了我那件米色毛衣的造型。我记得当时在想，天哪，我又出汗又臭。而且约翰还得抱我。这是，我觉得大家不会去想的事情。你知道，任何时候只要我有需要对某人耳语的戏，或者你需要
have to kiss, I would brush my teeth like three times and chew gum and eat a mint before. And anytime when you have to be close to someone, I would be very aware of my potential body odor. Yeah. At least our show wasn't a show with a bunch of close talkers because like you watch an episode of like the Sopranos, they get in each other's faces, they're like, listen here. And they're like right up to each other's face, like at least we didn't have that. That's true.
接吻的戏，我都会刷三遍牙，嚼口香糖，还在之前吃薄荷糖。任何需要靠近某人的时候，我都会对自己的潜在体味保持高度警惕。是的。至少我们的剧不是那种有很多“贴面密谈”角色的剧，因为就像你看《黑道家族》的一集，他们凑到对方脸前，说，听着。他们就贴在对方脸前，至少我们没有那种情况。这倒也是。
But when I watch those scenes because we're actors and we know, I think like, oh my God, there's no way they don't know what they had for lunch because that is some close talking. Well when Jim lifts Pam up at the dojo. At 14 minutes, 11 seconds. We got a lot of questions about this scene. I have questions. So go. Well, in Office Olympics, Angela has her bit about Pampong.
但当我看到那些戏时，因为我们是演员，我们懂，我会想，天哪，他们绝对知道对方午饭吃了什么，因为那贴得也太近了。嗯，当吉姆在道场抱起帕姆的时候。在14分11秒。我们收到了很多关于这场戏的问题。我有问题。所以，说吧。嗯，在办公室奥运会上，安吉拉有关于帕姆乒乓球的戏份。
Yes. And that's kind of the first time that Pam is made aware that someone else is aware. People are noticing. Yes. And now in this scene, Meredith clocks the interaction between Pam and Jim and that is what freaks out Pam. Also, your shirt came up and you could see your belly. Now I remember as your friend that week, you saying to me, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, people
是的。那可以说是帕姆第一次意识到另一个人意识到了。大家都在注意到这一点。是的。现在在这场戏里，梅雷迪思注意到了帕姆和吉姆之间的互动，正是这一点把帕姆吓坏了。还有，你的衬衫掀上去了，能看到你的肚子。现在我作为你的朋友，记得那周你对我说，哦天哪，哦天哪，大家
are going to see my belly. Because it said, you know, it picks up and your shirt kind of comes up and you are nervous about it. Yeah. So that was a fan question. Anthony asked, was it meant for your shirt to pull up when Jim lifted you or did it happen on accident and you went with it? It was in the script that my shirt would come up a little bit.
要看到我的肚子了。因为上面说，你知道，它被提起来了，你的衬衫有点往上跑，你为此感到紧张。是的。所以这是一个粉丝提问。安东尼问：吉姆抱你的时候，你的衬衫设计成会往上提，还是意外发生的，你就将计就计了？剧本里确实写了我的衬衫会稍微往上提一点。
And that was all to make it even more of a vulnerable thing for Pam that she was literally exposed. Yeah. Something that you were really embarrassed about. Yes. And wow, I wish my stomach looked like that today. I watched that scene. I knew you were like, why was I not wearing midriff tops every day when I looked like
这一切都是为了让帕姆感到更加脆弱，她简直是暴露无遗了。是的。这是你非常尴尬的事情。是的。天哪，我真希望我今天的肚子能长那样。我看了那场戏。我知道你当时在想，为什么我身材成那样的时候不天天穿露脐装呢？
that? I know. I knew you were going to say that because I mean, listen, we've had babies and everything changes after that and you're, I mean, you look phenomenal today, Jenna. You look phenomenal then. But I know I remember our bellies before babies. I remember. Well, I am kind of glad that it was scripted that you see my belly because I've got it
我知道。我早就知道你会这么说，因为我是说，听着，我们都生过孩子，之后一切都变了，你，我是说，珍娜，你今天看起来好极了。你当时看起来也好极了。但我知道，我记得我们生孩子前的肚子。我记得。好吧，我有点庆幸剧本里设计了能看到我的肚子，因为我现在有
on film now that at one time in my life, I had a cute little belly and belly button. So thank you, Jean and Lee for that. At 13 minutes, 56 seconds. That's my third time code, Angela. There is a poster in the background of this interaction between Jim and Pam. So we're all watching Jim and Pam. But in the background, there is a poster on the wall and it is one of my favorite things. It was like a favorite thing of all of us when we got to the dojo.
影像记录了，我生命中的某个时期，我也有一个可爱的小肚子和肚脐眼。所以为此我要感谢吉恩和李。在13分56秒。那是我的第三个时间码，安吉拉。在吉姆和帕姆互动的背景里有一张海报。所以我们都在看吉姆和帕姆。但在背景中，墙上有一张海报，这是我最喜欢的东西之一。当我们到达道场时，这是我们所有人都最喜欢的东西。
This was a set decoration poster that Jean and Lee wrote that set decoration had printed and put on the wall. It is the 10 rules of karate. Okay. All right. According to this dojo. I'm going to read them to you. Okay.
这是一张由吉恩和李编写的布景海报，让布景部门打印出来贴在墙上的。那是柔道十诫。好的。好吧。根据这个道场的规定。我要念给你们听。好的。
They're amazing. Number one, obey your parents. Okay. Number two, no junk food. Number three, do your homework. Number four, keep your room clean. Number five, maintain an indomitable spirit. Number six, don't fight with your siblings.
太棒了。第一条，听从父母的话。好的。第二条，不吃垃圾食品。第三条，做好功课。第四条，保持房间清洁。第五条，保持不屈不挠的精神。第六条，不要和兄弟姐妹打架。
Seven, practice, practice, practice. Eight, treat others the way you would like to be treated. Nine, be loyal to your country. And 10, have fun. So Lee told me he still has this poster. He asked to have it. He said they spent way too long writing these rules. I was going to say, I bet they spent like hours like just like cracking themselves up.
第七条，练习，练习，练习。第八条，你希望别人怎么对你，你就怎么对别人。第九条，忠于祖国。第十条，玩得开心。所以李告诉我他现在还留着这张海报。他要求把它留下。他说他们花在写这些规则上的时间太长了。我正想说，我敢打赌他们花了几个小时，一直在那儿逗得自己哈哈大笑。
It's amazing to me because I feel like it is this little detail that really hammers home that Dwight takes classes in a studio meant for children. Children, do your homework. These are kid based rules. And of course, you see that. You see that he's in a class with a bunch of 11 year olds, but I just think that is brilliant. Brilliant writing that poster. Okay.
我觉得这太神奇了，因为我觉得正是这个小细节，真正强调了德怀特是在一个专为儿童开设的工作室里上课。孩子们，做你们的作业。这些都是基于孩子的规则。当然，你能看出来。你看得出他是和一群11岁的孩子在一班，但我只是觉得这太绝了。这张海报的剧本写得太绝了。好吧。
So that was their version of the rules of karate, right? There's this thread on Reddit where people go back and forth. They were like, but Dwight says karate and then there's taekwondo this and there's this and this. So a little bit that the martial arts didn't quite line up in that dojo. Yeah. I think that makes sense too. I mean, Dwight is not maybe studying a pure form of any one martial art.
所以那是他们版本的柔道规则对吧？Reddit上有一个帖子，大家在上面争论不休。他们说，但德怀特说的是柔道，然后又有什么跆拳道这个那个的。所以有点像那个道场里的武术并不是很对口。是的。我觉得这也说得通。我是说，德怀特可能并没有在学习任何一种单一武术的正统流派。
Right. I have to talk about the fact that at 14 minutes, 11 seconds, I think that Pam is sending Jim Mick's signals. Of course she is. And I totally judged her a little bit because she was being really flirty and then when Meredith noticed, it wasn't until Meredith noticed that then she like pushed Jim away and then the look on John's face, he does such a fantastic job of looking wounded and confused and not really, he was so happy, but now he's like, now what happened?
对。我必须谈谈这件事：在14分11秒，我觉得帕姆在给吉姆发出混合信号。她当然是了。我完全有点评判她，因为她表现得很调情，然后当梅雷迪思注意到时，直到梅雷迪思注意到，她才把吉姆推开，然后约翰脸上的表情，他把那种受伤和困惑的表情演得太棒了，而且他真的不是，他刚才还那么高兴，但现在他就像是，这下怎么回事？
He did such a great job because Pam is sending him Mick's signals. She really is. But I mean, that's complicated, unrequited love for you. I know. What are you going to do? She's conflicted. She's conflicted. When Michael pins down Dwight at the dojo and is winning the fight, our director of
他演得太棒了，因为帕姆在给他发送混合信号。她确实在发。但我是说，那是你们的复杂、无疾而终的爱情。我知道。你还能怎么办？她内心纠结。她内心纠结。当迈克尔在道场压制住德怀特并且在决斗中获胜时，我们的摄影
photography, Randall Einhorn, who used to work on Survivor, so I want to say literally nothing surprises this man. He is a total pro. He never broke. He lost it. He lost it. He was laughing so hard that he had to take the camera off his shoulder and hold it out with his arm so that it wouldn't shake.
指导兰德尔·艾因霍恩，他以前在《幸存者》工作过，所以我想说，字面意义上没有什么能吓到这个男人。他是个绝对的专业人士。他从来没笑场过。他笑崩了。他彻底笑崩了。他笑得太厉害了，不得不把摄像机从肩膀上拿下来，用手臂举着，以免摄像机晃动。
He had tears like streaming down his face. Now it's the hardest I've ever seen him laugh. That's saying something because he was like a statue. Him and Oscar Nunez never break. Yeah. I have a question for you. Lance, when I was speaking to him, said to his knowledge, the fight was not choreographed and that he really believed that the stuff that Michael, that Steve was doing to reign
泪水从他脸颊流了下来。这是我见过他笑得最厉害的一次。这很说明问题，因为他平时就像个雕像一样。他和奥斯卡·努涅斯从不笑场。是的。我有个问题要问你。兰斯跟我交谈时说，据他所知，那场打斗并没有排练过，他真的相信迈克尔对德怀特做的那些动作——史蒂夫对雷恩做的那些，比如把他按在地上试图向他吐口水之类的一切——都是史蒂夫即兴发挥的特技。我问过李关于这事。他的记忆是，他们确实在拍摄间隙某天请了一位特技指导在现场跟他们合作。是的。所以兰斯当时不在场。没错。
as Dwight, like holding him down and trying to spit on him and all of that, that Steve improvised that. I asked Lee about that. His memory is that they did bring in a stunt coordinator to work with them on set one day during a break. Yeah. So Lance wouldn't have been there for that. That's right.
所以——但那个人没有去道场。没有去道场。你们真正拍的那天，他们不在场。所以在拍摄当天，他说他们就像史蒂夫、雷恩和肯·夸帕斯一样，现场想出了很多桥段，比如打字机那些动作。而且他说，他不记得他们拍了多少条，但非常多。但他还说当时天气真的很热，那些家伙进行所有那些假打动作后累坏了。
And so- But that person did not go to the dojo. Did not go to the dojo. The day that you actually did it, they were not present. And so on the day, he said they just like Steve and Reign and Ken Quapas just came up with a bunch of stuff like the typewriter stuff. And just he said, he doesn't remember how many takes they did, but it was a lot. But he said it was also really hot and those guys got really tired doing all the fake fighting.
从他们互相说话时气喘吁吁的样子就能看出来。确实如此。你注意到那场戏里菲利斯的拍立得相机了吗？哦，是的。她在那儿拍照，那是个拍立得相机？难道你不希望我们拥有那些照片吗？是的。
You can tell because they're winded when they're speaking to each other. They are. It's true. Did you clock Phyllis' disposable camera in the scene? Oh, yes. Where she's taking pictures and it's a disposable camera? Don't you wish we had those pictures? Yes.
谁有那些照片？肯定有人有。是的。菲尔·谢伊。菲尔·谢伊。我不知道。好吧。所以在经历了这次耻辱性的失败后，我们回到了办公室。
Who has those? Someone must. Yeah. Phil Shea. Phil Shea. I don't know. All right. So after this humiliating defeat, we go back to the office.
我们看到了迈克尔办公室里的一场戏，镜头一直延伸到停车场。他试图用手机给瑞恩打电话。那跟平时的迈克尔办公室不是同一个。你完全能看出来，就像是完全不同的。是的。所以我们有两个迈克尔的办公室。我们有一个迈克尔的办公室是在我们的搭景里，窗户后面只有一个有点模糊的幕布背景。
And we see a scene from Michael's office that goes down into the parking lot. And he tries to call Ryan on his cell phone. That was a different office than the usual Michael's office. You totally, like it's completely different. Yes. So we had two Michael's offices. We had one Michael's office that was on our set and it had just like a scrim backdrop behind the window that was kind of blurry.
而且它只是……那是假的。那是一种老式的假窗户设计。但每当我们需要拍摄迈克尔实际从窗户望向停车场的戏时，我们就会转移到编剧办公室。他们实际上就在编剧办公室里拍摄。是的。我在努力回想，那是迈克·希尔的办公室还是保罗·利伯斯坦的办公室？
And it was just... It was fake. It was an old fashioned fake out the window kind of thing. But whenever we had to shoot a scene where Michael was actually looking out of his window into the parking lot, we would move over to the writer's offices. And they literally would shoot in a writer's office. Yes. And I was trying to remember, was it Mike Shearer's office or Paul Lieberstein's office?
他们两人中的一个，在迈克尔的办公室里工作，那里被随便装饰成了迈克尔的办公室的样子。然后到了拍摄时间，他们就会被赶出办公室，布景部门会进来布置一番。然后他们就得用那个地方拍摄，那天他们也没法在自己的办公室里写剧本。但那些墙有点像绿色。是的。
They, one of the two of them, worked in Michael's office and it was loosely decorated as Michael's office. And then when it was time to shoot, they would get kicked out of their office and set dressing would come in and zhuzh it up. And then they would have to use that to shoot and they couldn't write in their office that day. But the walls are like kind of a green color. Yes.
这一点一直都是真的。根本不搭。就像我在想，伙计们，墙的颜色不一样啊。嗯，有趣的是，其他所有的哦，编剧都可以装饰自己的办公室。哦，门迪的办公室装饰得可漂亮了。哦，肯定的。当然。是的。
That was always true. That don't match. Like I was like, guys, the walls are not the same. Well, it's funny too because all the other writers could decorate their offices. Oh, Mindy's office was so decorated. Oh, for sure. Of course. Yeah.
当然。墙上贴着海报，但他们不能这么做。我觉得那是保罗的。我也觉得那是保罗的。因为我记得。那是我的记忆。如果不是保罗的，那保罗也真没花什么心思去装饰。两人中必有一个。
Of course. There were posters on the wall, but they couldn't do it. I feel like it was Paul's. I think it was Paul's as well. Because I remember. That's my memory. If it wasn't Paul's, then Paul just really didn't make a lot of effort to decorate. One of the two.
我记得他的办公室挺空荡荡的。所以接下来，迈克尔叫我们其余人去签表。他放弃了。确实如此。在节目的最后，真正签字的人是托比、斯坦利、安吉拉和帕姆。他们都挤在前台聚在一起，我很喜欢拍那场戏，因为其他人那天都已经回家了。
I remember his office being pretty bare. So next up, Michael tells the rest of us to sign the forms. He's given up. For sure. At the end of the show, the people who actually signed the reports are Toby, Stanley, Angela, and Pam. They're all grouped together at the reception desk, and I loved shooting that scene because everyone else had gone home for the day.
除了德怀特。没错。他在自己的办公桌前。但办公室里大部分人都走了。而我们这群人，很少有机会一起拍小型的群戏，只有我们几个。我对拍摄那段戏有着非常美好的回忆。我也是。我也是。
Except for Dwight. That's right. Who was at his desk. But most of the office was gone. And that group of us, we were very rarely in little scenes together, just us. And I have very fond memories of shooting that. Me too. Me too.
那真的、真的很开心。我还有一个时间码，就在最后结束前，17分57秒。大家都在收拾东西准备下班。你猜谁坐在梅雷迪思对面？谁？瑞恩。是的，那是他的桌子。
That was really, really fun. I have one thing that is a time code that was right before the end there at 17 minutes and 57 seconds. People are packing up for the day. Guess who's sitting across from Meredith? Who? Ryan. Yeah, that was his desk.
但克里德在哪儿？克里德当时好像还没有自己的办公桌。我不知道。克里德什么时候接管了瑞恩的桌子，瑞恩又是什么时候搬回走廊隔间的？这些都是好问题。我知道。瑞恩，嗯，最后记得我们把走廊里的那个小储藏室改成了瑞恩的办公室，我觉得。
But where was Creed? Creed didn't really have a desk yet. I don't know. When does Creed take over Ryan's desk, and when does Ryan move back to the annex? These are good questions. I know. Did Ryan, well, eventually remember we turned that closet in the hallway into Ryan's office, I feel like.
差不多。那张桌子有点像个杂物堆，对吧？我觉得我看见过德文在那儿，看见过瑞恩在那儿，看见过克里德在那儿。它是什么时候变成克里德的桌子的？还有在这集结尾，当大家排队离开时，我们看到了露安的出场。哦，那是露安。露安。露安是我们的替身兼群众演员之一。
A little bit. That desk was kind of the catch-all, right? I feel like I've seen Devon there, I've seen Ryan there, I've seen Creed there. When does it become Creed's desk? Also in this episode, at the end, when people are filing out, we see an appearance of Luanne. Oh, there's Luanne. Luanne. Luanne was one of our stand-ins slash extras.
她通常会坐在隔间里，人们总是问那是谁。所以露安走过去了。没错。我觉得有两件事我想告诉大家，我们在这次重看中会致力于追踪的，一是门迪的头发，二是克里德什么时候有了自己的办公桌。好吧，所以先记下这个。外面可能已经有人知道了。他们会写信来说，嘿，你们看，克里德在这一集就坐在那儿。
Who would normally sit in the annex, and people always say who is that. So Luanne walks by. That's right. I feel like the two things I want to tell you guys we're going to be dedicated to tracking in this rewatch is Mindy's hair, and when does Creed get his desk? Okay, so just know that. Someone out there probably already knows. They're going to write in and say, you guys, Creed sits there in episode.
告诉我们。告诉我们。解开这个谜团吧。好的，迈克尔在结尾把德怀特带进了会议室，他说他一整天都在考验他，他晋升德怀特为助理区域经理。他没有公告，没有加薪，也没有新办公室，但德怀特高兴极了。他在所有的名片上都写上了这个头衔。真是又纯真又可爱。
Tell us. Tell us. Solve this mystery. Okay, Michael takes Dwight into the conference room here at the end, and he says he's been testing him all day, and he promotes Dwight to assistant regional manager. He gets no announcement, no raise, and no new office, but Dwight is so happy. He wights out to the on all of his business cards. It's so pure and sweet.
我知道。太可爱了，尽管迈克尔说，这其实不是个真正的职位，但这其实不重要。德怀特根本没听进去那部分。德怀特才不在乎呢。除了“助理区域经理”，他什么话也听不见。然后这就引出了迈克尔那句著名的独白：我是愿意被人害怕还是被人爱戴？很简单，两者兼要。
I know. It's so sweet, although Michael's like, it's not really a real thing, but it doesn't really matter. Dwight isn't hearing that part. Dwight doesn't care. He doesn't hear any words except assistant regional manager. And then this leads us to the famous Michael talking headline, would I rather be feared or loved, easy, both.
我希望人们对他们有多爱我感到恐惧。我曾在枕头上看到过这句话被绣上去。我在衬衫上也见过。我希望人们对他们有多爱我感到恐惧。好编剧。是的。写得太好了。那场戏就是这样。
I want people to be afraid of how much they love me. I have seen that stitched on pillows. I have seen that on shirts. I want people to be afraid of how much they love me. Good writers. Yes. Such good writing. And that was the fight.
那就是那场戏。所以下周，我们将带着《客户》回归。客户。这也许是我最喜欢的第二季单集，虽然还有《受伤》。我喜欢《受伤》。你喜欢《受伤》，珍娜。你还穿了一件你在网上买的关于《受伤》的T恤。我在Etsy上买了一件。
That was the fight. So next week, we will be back with the client. The client. This is maybe my favorite season two episode, although there's also the injury. I love the injury. You love the injury, Jenna. You wore a shirt like that you've bought online of the injury. I bought a shirt from Etsy.
对。印着烤熟的脚的T恤。对。你会穿的。你经常穿。那是你最喜欢的T恤之一。她并没有打扰你。确实没有。
Yeah. Of a grilled foot. Yeah. That you would wear. You would wear it a lot. It was like one of your favorite shirts. She didn't bother you. It didn't.
我穿得太勤了吗？没有，并没有。但它就是让我觉得好笑。有天你穿着印有烤熟的脚的T恤出现，而我穿的T恤是我们节目的一个内部梗，印着克里德在香港的动作玩偶形象。呃-哈。我们俩……我们有没有意识到自己可能是他们俩的超级狂热粉丝？
Did I wear it too often? No, it didn't. But it just made me laugh. There was a day that you showed up in your shirt with the grilled foot and I had a shirt that was like an inside joke on our show of Creed as an action figure in Hong Kong. Uh-huh. And we both... Do we realize we were maybe too big a fan of them?
我们就像是，我们在干什么？我们竟然穿着我们节目的周边T恤到处走。所以下周，我们要谈论的不是《受伤》，而是《客户》。我们到时候见。到时候见。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。
We're like, what are we doing? We're just walking around in shirts from our show. So next week, we will be talking about not the injury, but the client. We'll see you then. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher.
我们的音频工程师是萨姆·皮弗。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听无广告版本的节目以及我们的彩蛋节目“糖果袋”，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码：Office。这集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。
Our sound engineer is Sam Peefer. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of the show and our bonus episode's candy bag, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音响工程师是萨姆·皮费尔。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的节目以及我们的特别节目彩蛋，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月 Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码 Office。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。